ARE ALL  INVOLVED.
CARTER AND FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST GREGG JAR AD.
DIFFERENT STORIES, ONE OF THE
STORIES COMING FROM SOURCES IS
THAT ANDREW WEISSMANN CONTACTED
BY THE AP.
THEY WANTED TO MEET WITH HIM.
AND THEY WENT TO HAVE THIS MEET
NOTHING THE DOJ, ON APRIL 11TH.
AND AT THIS MEETING, THEY WERE
APPARENTLY GOING TO SHARE
DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION WITH
WEISSMANN AND OTHER ATTENDES.
I SPOKE WITH A SOURCE FAMILIAR
WITH THE CONDITION.
THE APDENIED THE CLAIM THAT THEY
WOULD SHARE INFORMATION WITH
WEISSMANN.
REPORTERS AND THEY DID NOT BRING
ANYTHING WITH THEM WHAT SO EVER.
NO DOCUMENTS AND SHARED NOTHING
WITH THEM AND IN FACT, THE
SOURCE SAID THERE WAS
A TELEPHONE CALL PLACED BY ONE
OF THE AP- REPORTERS ON
APRIL 8TH, TO ANDREW WEISSMANN.
>> Sean: ISN'T HE COMPROMISED
AND PREJUDICE.
>> WHY WOULD HE LIE ABOUT THIS,
RIGHT?
IF THIS IS THE STORY COMING FROM
ON WEISMANN'S SIDE.
THE SOURCES SAY THERE WAS
A PROBLEM.
HE SET UP THE MEETING WITHOUT
THE APPROPRIATE PROCEDURES IN
PLACE AND DIDN'T CALL THE PEOPLE
HE NEEDED TO CALL.
>> Sean: IF I AM PAUL MANAFORT'S
ATTORNEY AND UNRAVELLING AND YOU
>> Sean: WHY DIDN'T HE RECUSE
HIMSELF.
>> HE IS HAVE BEEN FIRED.
DOJ WILL NOT COMMENT ABOUT AN
ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
IF YOU DO, YOU ARE FIRED.
IF HE GIVES INFORMATION OR
COLLECTS INFORMATION, EITHER
WAY, FROM THESE REPORTERS, HE IS
BE FIRED.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> I COMMUNICATED THE E-MAIL
WITH A FORMER DOJ OFFICIAL WHO
WAS THERE MORE THAN TEN YEARS,
ABSOLUTELY MANAFORT'S LAWYER
VOTING FOR TRUMP.
THEY NEED A CHANGE MUCH VENUE IF
WE HAVE FAIRNESS INSPECT OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
PAUL MANAFORT CAN'T GET A FAIR
TRIAL IN THAT AREA.
>> MANAFORT'S LAWYERS FILE WOULD
A LAWSUIT.
>>>> Sean: SO MANY MOVING
BERNIE.
INFLUENCE THE GENERAL ELECTION
AND THEN THAT SAME DOSSIER IS
USED TO GET FISAL WARRANTS
AGAINST A CANDIDATE AND
PRESIDENT-ELECT BASED ON FAULTY
PROPAGANDA AND LIES THAT SHE
PAID FOR.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
IN THE WORST SPY NOVEL.
>> SEAN, THIS WILL GO DOWN THE
GREATEST DIRTY TRICK IN AMERICAN
POLITICAL HISTORY.
LOOKING AT THE WHAT THEY
ACCOMPLISHED OR TRIED TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THIS.
FOR THIS INVESTMENT OF FUSION
GPS.
RUSSIAN TIES X. GOT THE FBI TO
TAKE AN UNSOURCED DOCUMENT.
FUSION GPS AND GLENN SIMPSON'S
TELL.
WE DO OPEN SOURCE RESOURCE.
THERE WAS NO OPEN INFORMATION
HE KNEW THERE WAS NOTHING TO IT.
>> Sean: HE HAD AN AGENDA LIKE
COMEY AND SO MANY OTHERS HAD AN
AGENDA.
SARAH, GOING BACK, YOU BROKE THE
STORY WITH JOHN ON THIS PROGRAM
ABOUT WARRANTS AT TRUMP TOWER
BEFORE ANYBODY ELSE IN MARCH?
>> YES, IT WAS IN MARCH OF LAST
YEAR.
>> Sean: RIGHT HERE ON THIS
PROGRAM.
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS USED.
I AM GETTING CONFLICTING
REPORTS.
IT WAS USED IN SOME CAPACITY AND
IT WAS LARGE SIGNIFICANT WAY TO
GET THE WARRANTS.
>> WELL, I THINK SEAN, WE NEED
TO HAVE AN INVESTIGATION BE MADE
PUBLIC BEFORE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS
LOOKING INTO THE DOSSIER AND THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
LOOKING INTO IT.
IT PLAYED A PARTIAL ROLE OR
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN GETTING THE
WARRANTS.
>> Sean: SIGNIFICANT IS IT THE
ROLE I AM HEARING.
>> YES, WHAT ROLE.
AND IF IT WAS NOT VERIFIED.
I AGREE WITH PETER.
>> Sean: DID THEY KNOWINGLY LIE
TO THE COURT AND GIVE LIES TO
OBTAIN WARRANTS AGAINST
A POLITICAL OPPONENT?
THAT MAKES WATERGATE BASICALLY
LOOK LIKE KIND GARTERN COMPARED
TO THIS.
>> YES, IF THEY DID.
WHAT IS IT.
>> Sean: RELEASE IT.
AND I WANT TO SEE IT.
AND THE PUBLIC DESERVES TO SEE
IT, GREG?
>> IT IS I FRAUD ON THE COURT TO
OBTAIN A WARRANT WITH A FRAUD
DOCUMENT AND YOU KNOW THAT DOJ
AND THE FBI KNEW IT WAS FALSE
EVIDENCE.
IT COMES FROM SOURCES THAT ARE
WELL KNOWN IN THE KREMLIN TO LIE
AND PROVIDE FALSE INFORMATION.
THEY NEVER USED IT AS A PRETEXT
TO DESTROY TRUMP OR LAUNCH THE
INFORMATION AFTER THEY HAD
ALREADY CLEARED HILLARY CLINTON